New York, Madison Avenue. Ici a lieu ce
matin une vente aux enchères exceptionnelle.
Mesdames et messieurs, merci d'être venus. Je
peux ouvrir les enchères facilement à 70 000$.
70 000$, c'est la mise à prix pour cette
montre de plongée en acier, le modèle Milgauss.
À sa sortie, il avait fait un flop.
50 ans plus tard, on se l'arrache.
Ces enchères, c'est le rendez-vous à ne pas
manquer pour les collectionneurs du monde entier.
Ici, chacun a déjà une Rolex, quand ce n'est pas deux.
Vous avez deux Rolex au poignet ?
Oui, j'aime les Rolex. Le matin, j'ai du mal à choisir.
On débute à 70 000$. Y a-t-il une enchère dans la salle ?
Dans quelques secondes, le marteau du
commissaire priseur va faire un heureux.
75 000, 80 000, 85 000, 90 000...
Les enchères font tourner la tête.
130 000. Et avec vous au téléphone ?
160 000 maintenant. Avec Etienne ?
Le prix grimpe à 160 000.
Non ? Personne à 170 000 ? Donc c'est toujours 160 000
une fois, 160 000 deux fois... Adjugé à 160 000.
La Rolex ancienne est adjugée 160 000$. Un peu plus de 100 000€,
C'est 30 fois le prix de la moins chère
des montres neufs de la marque, environ 3 000€.
Si les enchères crèvent ainsi le plafond, c'est que ces montres sont aussi des montres de stars et qu'elles font rêver.
Cet homme en possède toute une collection, l'une
de ses préférées est une vraie montre d'espion.
Combien de Rolex avez-vous ?
J'en ai 200. Celle-là, c'est la Big Crown.
C'est la montre de James Bond.
C'est exactement la montre que portait Sean Connery
en 1962 dans James Bond contre le Dr No.
Un cocktail gagnant qui mêle le chic et l'action.
Et la liste des stars n'en finit pas de s'allonger.
Bruce Willis, Michael Jackson, Arnold Schwarzenegger,
Maradona, Fidel Castro ou le Che.
Et même le Dalaï-lama ou le pape Jean-Paul II. À chacun sa
Rolex, la montre des riches, des célèbres et des puissants.
Le président Nicolas Sarkozy, lui aussi, a tenté le
poignet de stars, quitte à devenir sujet de moqueries.
Tout le monde n'est pas Sean Connery.
Quel prix les amoureux de la marque sont-ils prêts
à investir pour se payer cette part de rêve ?
Comment est-elle devenue la montre par excellence ?
La marque la plus copiée au monde
est-elle menacée par la contrefaçon ?
Voici l'histoire d'un horloger qui, depuis 100 ans,
a totalement révolutionné l'univers des montres.
Monsieur Rolex, c'est lui. En fait, le roi de
la montre s'appelle Hans Wilsdorf, il est allemand.
Orphelin à douze ans, il s'installe à Londres en 1903
comme petit employé dans une fabrique de montres.
Wilsdorf a le génie de l'horlogerie et le goût de l'excellence.
Avec quelques économies, il fonde une petite usine
qui ne s'appelle pas encore Rolex mais Wilsdorf & Davis.
À l'époque, il y a de nombreux fabricants,
mais un seul modèle existe pour les hommes.
Celui-ci, la montre à gousset.
Wilsdorf, lui, fait un autre pari. Et si la
montre passait de la poche aux poignées.
À ce jour, peu de fabricants ont osé le faire.
L'histoire de Rolex, l'Anglais James Dowling,
la connaît sur le bout des doigts.
Pour ce spécialiste, proposer des montres bracelets
aux hommes est une révolution, au début du XXᵉ siècle.
Ce qu'il a décidé de faire, c'est de focaliser
la production sur les montres bracelets.
À l'époque, elles venaient tout juste de faire
leur apparition mais elle était réservée aux femmes.
Aucun homme n'en portait. Un vrai homme portait
une belle montre gousset avec une grosse chaîne.
C'est un enterrement de première classe pour la montre de poche.
La montre bracelet pour homme est un coup de tonnerre,
Dans le monde de l'horlogerie. Et ce sont
les coups de canon qui vont faire le reste.
Puis la guerre de 1914 démarre.
C'est la première guerre de l'ère industrielle. Des
milliers et des milliers de combattants font mouvement.
Il est important de pouvoir synchroniser leurs actions.
Dans les tranchées, il fait froid,
il y a de la boue, de la poussière.
Tout le monde porte des tuniques encombrantes. Il
est donc difficile d'utiliser des montres gousset.
Et des officiers adoptent alors la montre bracelet. Et plus personne ne peut dire que ce sont des montres réservées aux femmes.
Des montres bracelets au poignet des
poilus. Un coup de marketing inattendu.
À l'époque, on parle encore de montres
Wilsdorf, mais ça ne va pas durer.
En pleine guerre, un nom germanique, c'est la faillite assurée. Wilsdorf rebaptise donc sa société. Elle s'appellera Rolex.
Il choisit le terme Rolex à partir du
mot rolling, "roulant" en anglais,
Et ça donnait une idée de mouvement et une montre, c'est ça.
Il a aussi choisi Rolex parce que c'était le moment
où les compagnies devenaient internationales.
Et beaucoup de compagnies choisissaient des noms
brefs de 4 à 5 lettres qui ne voulaient rien dire,
Mais qui sonnaient de la même manière dans
toutes les langues. Comme Kodak, par exemple.
À l'issue de la Grande Guerre, une
deuxième révolution technologique,
Va permettre à Rolex de prendre une
avance décisive sur ses concurrents.
Cette révolution, James Dowling, la porte au poignet.
Je porte un prototype de Rolex Oyster de 1926.
C'est une très belle montre qui se découvre
élégamment quand la manche remonte.
Elle n'est pas m'as-tu-vu, elle n'est pas ostentatoire.
Oyster, l'huître en anglais. C'est la première
montre au monde à être complètement étanche.
Brevetée en 1926, aujourd'hui encore, elle épate les spécialistes.
Paris, sixième arrondissement. Antoine de Macedo
connaît chaque rouage de cette Rolex étanche.
Son magasin, c'est un peu la clinique des montres d'occasion.
Pour lui, aucun autre boîtier n'est aussi résistant.
C'est le fameux boîtier Oyster. Et c'est
vraiment de nos jours certainement,
Le meilleur système qui a été mis au point
pour les montres étanches, évidemment.
Je vais la mettre dans la machine.
Cette machine est un simulateur de pression sous marine.
Une salle de torture pour les montres.
À l'époque, dans les années 30, quand
c'est sorti, chez les horlogers,
Il y avait un présentoir avec un aquarium et les
montres étaient présentées en vitrine dans l'aquarium.
Donc c'était quand même assez étonnant.
Voilà, on la ressort. Il n'y a pas d'eau à l'intérieur,
il n'y a pas de buée, donc la montre est étanche.
Je vais vous montrer la même chose avec
une montre qui n'est pas étanche.
On va mettre un peu de pression, vous voyez les bulles qui sortent, donc la montre fuit de partout là, à vrai dire donc vous voyez...
Une fois sortie de l'eau, le résultat est sans appel.
Là, on voit les gouttes d'eau à l'intérieur
du fond de boîte et dans le mouvement.
La Rolex, elle, est bien étanche et pas seulement à l'eau.
Avec le boîtier Oyster, son mécanisme est
dorénavant protégée de toutes les agressions.
Les poussières, l'humidité nuisent au
bon fonctionnement d'un mouvement.
Donc, le fait de mettre un mouvement dans un boîtier
parfaitement étanche, celui-ci aura une meilleure marche,
Les entretiens seront beaucoup plus espacés.
Étanches à la poussière et à l'eau,
Wilsdorf tient une montre fiable.
Et pour la faire connaître, il va l'offrir à
une aventurière anglaise, Mercedes Gleitze.
Cette jeune secrétaire est l'une des premières
femmes à tenter la traversée de la Manche à la nage.
Nous sommes en octobre 1927. La jeune femme
nage pendant 15h dans une eau glaciale.
Elle tient le choc, la montre aussi.
La marque affiche son triomphe à la une du Daily Mail.
Elle est désormais synonyme d'exploit et
les ventes explosent en boutique.
Mais déjà, l'infatigable Wilsdorf pense à sa prochaine révolution.
Une montre sans contrainte, sans
mécanisme à remonter tous les jours.
Il invente donc une montre entièrement automatique,
un mouvement perpétuel miniature.
Voici la version géante. Le principe
imaginé par Rolex est exactement le même.
Une des grandes forces de Rolex a été de faire une
montre qui se remontais par le mouvement cinétique.
Vous avez un rotor à la montre, vous voyez, qui traduit chacun
de vos mouvements en une force démultipliée par un rouage,
Et qui va vers le ressort, ce qui
évite d'avoir à remonter la montre.
Ça fait des montres quand même beaucoup plus précises
souvent que des montres à remontage manuel.
Vous voyez le fait de remonter une montre, ça a aussi son charme.
Mais l'automatisme, oui, c'est vraiment une vraie révolution.
C'est un mouvement conçu de manière extrêmement
logique. Il n'y a rien de superflu.
Pour moi, c'est vraiment une bête de concours.
Une bête de concours qui va laisser K.O. pendant de nombreuses années ses principaux concurrents Omega, Breguet et Longines.
Place Vendôme à Paris, le haut lieu de l'expertise en bijouterie.
Jean-claude Sabrier est un spécialiste
international des montres anciennes.
Pour lui, le génie de la marque suisse,
c'est le brevet de la montre automatique.
C'est comme cela qu'elle a tout verrouillé.
La force de Rolex est d'avoir pris, dès
l'origine, dix ans d'avance sur ses concurrents.
Rolex a pris des brevets très sérieux, pratiquement
le brevet Rolex de 31, l'a protégé jusqu'en 41.
En 41, il y a eu la guerre, donc c'était fini. Il n'y a pas
eu de possibilité de développement de ses concurrents.
Omega n'a sorti ses premières montres à
remontage automatique que dans les années 50.
Rolex avait de toute façon une avance de 20 ans.
Après la Seconde Guerre mondiale, rien de nouveau dans les
boîtiers Rolex mais Hans Wilsdorf cherche à faire un nouveau coup.
Il invente l'Explorer, une montre particulièrement
robuste taillée pour les aventuriers.
Il décide de l'envoyer sur le toit du monde. 1953, l'alpiniste Edmund Hillary et son coéquipier Tensing Norgay,
Décident de s'attaquer à la conquête de
l'Everest, une première mondiale !
Rolex au poignet, piolet à la main et crampons aux
pieds, la cordée britannique réussit son exploit.
La marque suisse aussi.
Le plus haut sommet du monde, l'Everest est vaincu.
Les habitants de Katmandou, capitale du Népal,
Ont fait un accueil triomphal à l'équipe victorieuse.
Le sherpa Tensing, leur compatriote, son
camarade de cordée, le Néo-Zélandais Hillary,
Et les autres membres de l'expédition que commandait le colonel. Les premiers dans l'histoire, les Anglais ont vaincu l'Everest !
Au sommet de l'Everest, Rolex atteint
aussi le sommet de sa notoriété.
Campagne de pub tous azimuts autour de l'explorer.
Il faut convaincre le public d'acheter
la montre de l'alpiniste Hillary.
Pour le publicitaire Jacques Séguéla, ce coup
de pub est un authentique coup de génie.
Ayant affirmé sa valeur de marque qui est
la recherche permanente de l'exception,
Il ne prendra, pour servir sa marque,
que des célébrités qui expriment,
Et parce qu'elles ont en eux cette
recherche permanente de l'exception.
Autrement dit, c'est une montre pour gens qui prennent des risques. C'est une montre pour des gens qui sont les actifs de la vie,
Et qui peuvent à tout moment plonger
dans la mer ou monter dans les nuages.
Peu de temps après le Toit du monde, la
marque va taquiner le fond des mers.
En 1953, le scientifique Jacques Piccard plonge en sous marin
avec une montre prototype accroché à l'extérieur de l'engin.
3000 mètres plus bas, elle bat un
nouveau record de profondeur cette fois.
Dans la foulée, la marque décline ce prototype en version
grand public, étanche à 100 mètres, baptisé Submariner.
Les retombées commerciales sont immédiates.
Aujourd'hui encore, c'est le modèle vedette du catalogue.
Dans les nuages ou dans les profondeurs des abysses, à chaque
fois, le constructeur suisse joue du marketing avec précision,
Une seule condition, rester la montre de l'exploit.
Près de 2 milliards de chiffre d'affaires,
800 000 montres vendues l'an dernier,
Il n'existe aucun chiffre officiel publié par la
marque mais les estimations donnent le vertige.
Pour fabriquer ces bijoux, près de 6000 employés
travaillent dans la plus grande discrétion.
Qui définit cette stratégie du secret ?
Comment se protège t-elle de la concurrence ?
Direction Genève, la ville coffre fort. C'est
vrai pour les banques autant que pour les montres.
Cet immeuble de verre, c'est la maison Rolex, citadelle imprenable.
Interdite au public et encore plus aux caméras.
Les curieux ne sont pas les bienvenus.
J'ai des gens qui sont en train de
faire une prise de vue du bâtiment...
Ok oui, merci.
- C'est une violation de domicile.
- Ici c'est privé jusque là.
- Jusqu'où ?
- Là, c'est l'extérieur.
Le culte du secret. Même les amoureux de la marque sont éconduits.
C'est le cas D'osvaldo Patrizzi. C'est lui qui a mis en
place les premières ventes aux enchères de Rolex anciennes.
Mais lorsqu'il a demandé le concours
de la marque, il a trouvé porte close.
L'horloger suisse l'a complètement snobé.
Moi j'aime leurs produits, je n'aime pas leur façon de gérer.
Mais je ne suis pas un actionnaire Rolex,
je suis un observateur extérieur.
Rolex, c'est un produit exceptionnel fait par
des personnes qui connaissent bien leur métier,
Mais qui ne connaissent pas l'art de communiquer sauf avec des grands coups de millions pour faire de la publicité.
Pour pénétrer dans cette usine, c'est
un véritable scénario à la James Bond.
Rolex, championne de l'innovation, déborde
aussi d'imagination quand il s'agit de se cacher.
Empreintes rétiniennes, empreintes digitales, code d'accès.
Des mesures de sécurité exceptionnelles pour cultiver
le secret mais aussi pour protéger un trésor.
En effet, pour fabriquer ces montres, la marque suisse
est le plus grand consommateur d'or après les Etats.
Un empire et une fortune détenue par
des propriétaires eux aussi très mystérieux.
Qui sont les détenteurs des actions Rolex ?
C'est une fondation, donc il n'y a pas
un vrai patron, il y a des responsables,
Donc il y a la famille Heiniguer après Wilsdorf,
ils ont pris Rolex entre leurs mains et la gère.
Ce sont eux les grands patrons aujourd'hui
mais ce n'est pas leur société.
La société appartient à une fondation.
Et là, je crois que Wilsdorf a bien vu.
Cette fondation la voici.
Quelques bureaux dans un immeuble anonyme.
Et ici comme à l'usine, silence.
Moi je peux pas vous donner des informations
comme ça sans savoir qui vous êtes.
Malheureusement je ne peux rien vous dire.
Rolex est donc détenue par une fondation,
c'est écrit dans ses statuts.
Autrement dit, Rolex n'est pas cotée en Bourse, elle
ne figure pas non plus au registre du commerce.
À l'origine, Hans Wilsdorf voulait protéger sa marque
et ses héritiers de toute tentative de rachat.
Aujourd'hui, selon Eric Pichet, analyste financier à la Bourse de Paris, ce statut privilégié est une arme économique redoutable.
L'avantage, c'est que vous ne donnez aucune information
aux concurrents puisque vous savez qu'en France,
Lorsque vous avez une société, même si elle n'est pas cotée d'ailleurs, vous devez déposer les comptes au registre du commerce,
Ces comptes sont consultables par n'importe qui, y compris par
les concurrents et surtout par les concurrents d'ailleurs.
Le fait de ne donner aucune information ni sur le chiffre d'affaires, ni sur le dividende, ni sur la stratégie,
Vous met totalement à l'abri des indiscrétions des concurrents.
En revanche, vous, vous pouvez consulter sans problème,
Les données que les concurrents sont obligés,
de par la législation suisse ou française,
De donner tout simplement à leurs actionnaires.
Ce sont des informations qui sont publiques,
Donc vous disposez là d'un avantage
comparatif par rapport aux autres.
Vous ne dites rien sur vos affaires et
vous pouvez regarder ce que font les autres.
Malgré toutes ces embûches, une marque gagne
du terrain et devient un concurrent menaçant.
Elle est Suisse, elle aussi, c'est Omega.
L'expert Jean-Claude Sabrier observe
cette guerre entre les deux marques.
Elle se joue jusqu'à la place Vendôme, à Paris.
Voici la future boutique Rolex. Et vous voyez, ce n'est pas par hasard, c'est place Vendôme, un des lieux privilégiés de Paris.
Il y a des concurrents à côté ?
Bien sûr. Toutes les marques de montres sont ici.
Nous allons avoir, à 50 mètres vous allez voir Omega.
Et voici la nouvelle boutique Omega qui vient juste d'ouvrir.
Pour affronter la marque à la couronne, Omega n'hésite
pas à utiliser les mêmes bonnes vieilles recettes.
1957, comme Rolex, Omega crée sa montre de l'exploit.
La Speedmaster. Et avec ce modèle,
elle réussit le coup du XXᵉ siècle.
C'est elle qui sera choisie par la NASA pour équiper
ses astronautes et deviendra la première montre,
À faire le voyage sur la Lune.
1995, comme Rolex, Omega se lance sur le marché
de l'espionnage au poignet de James Bond.
Les montres Omega de Pierce Brosnan et Daniel Craig
remplacent désormais la Submariner de Sean Connery.
À chaque fois qu'un nouveau James Bond sort, les
ventes d'Omega font un bond. Ah oui, c'est frappant !
Omega gagne du terrain tous les jours.
Comment ça se fait qu'ils n'arrivent pas à les rattraper ?
Ce n'est pas en dix ans qu'on peut rattraper un tel retard.
Omega est un concurrent sérieux.
Mais la vraie menace, le fondateur de Rolex
n'y avait jamais songé. C'est la contrefaçon.
Dans les rouages parfaitement huilée de la marque,
c'est le grain de sable qui risque de tout gripper.
Spécialiste de montres anciennes, Fabrice Guéroux
a fait de la chasse aux copies son hobby.
Et des fausses Rolex, il en entend parler tous les jours.
La première chose que quelqu'un vous demande
quand vous sortez une Rolex toute neuve,
Vous allez au restaurant, manger avec
des amis, c'est une vraie ou une fausse ?
C'est la première question qu'on vous
pose. C'est le truc hallucinant, quoi !
C'est à croire qu'il y en a autant sur le
marché en contrefaçons qu'en montres originales.
Sa première Rolex, il l'a acheté sur Internet.
Et il est allé de surprise en surprise.
Et d'un coup j'ai vu des montres à 3 000$,
le même modèle à 650 chez un autre en achat immédiat,
Je me suis dit bon quand même, il y a un problème.
Et je me suis aperçu en fait, petit à petit,
qu'il y avait pas mal de contrefaçons sur le net.
Trouver une fausse montre sur Internet, rien de plus simple.
Il suffit de taper les cinq lettres de
la marque dans un moteur de recherche.
Donc en haut le site officiel Rolex donc ça c'est normal.
Mais juste en dessous du site officiel, les sites des faussaires.
Nous entrons dans la caverne d'Ali Baba des imitations.
Plus de 450 modèles. Tous faux.
On peut choisir par modèle, Daytona, Submariner, Sea-Dweller,
Yacht‑Master, GMT-Master, Explorer 1,
Explorer 2, Day-Date, Datejust Man,...
Donc voilà, au niveau des Submariner, il y a tous les prix. Il y a même des modèles qui n'existent pas, le modèle marron à fond blanc.
Nous choisissons la Submariner en
acier. C'est la promo de la semaine.
229$, 20 fois moins cher que la vraie.
Pour la commander en ligne, donc, on va ouvrir un compte.
La tentation est grande d'en commander une deuxième.
Cette fois, nous visons les montres de collection.
Ce sont des montres qui se monnaient entre 5 et 100 000€,
Donc on va aller voir ce qu'ils
proposent. Vous avez plusieurs modèles.
On va aller regarder le modèle
militaire qui est une Submariner 5517.
C'est une montre très rare, très dure à trouver et qui se monnaye aujourd'hui entre dix et 15 000€ suivant l'état de la montre.
Donc voilà, on va commander celle-ci aussi.
Total de nos achats, un peu plus de 300€ pour une paire de Rolex.
En un clin d'oeil, le bon de commande est
expédié en Chine, l'adresse de notre faussaire.
Le contact là-bas en Chine s'appelle ****.
Fabrice, n'a plus qu'à régler la facture par la poste.
Je vais payer.
- On aura nos colis dans combien de temps ?
- Une dizaine de jours.
Six jours plus tard, la commande est déjà là.
La contrefaçon en service rapide.
Pour déballer le paquet, Fabrice Guéroux se rend chez
deux autres spécialistes en montres de collection.
Et là, surprise, dans l'enveloppe, pas de
traces de montres, mais un jouet en plastique.
On a un jouet... un jouet en plastique.
Ça sent l'escroquerie.
Original.
Un jeu en plastique, ils ont balancé ! T'y crois toi ?
Mais le matou est un cheval de Troie.
Il n'a pas livré tous ses secrets.
Ah oui, en fait, il faut appuyer sur une espèce de vis.
- Incroyable.
- À l'intérieur du jouet.
- Il y en a deux ?
- Oui, oui deux montres.
- Bien emballées.
- C'est ce que t'as commandé ?
Il y a la militaire.
L'apparence, c'est vraiment l'apparence d'une Rolex.
Regarde-moi ça, elle paraît aussi vraie qu'une vraie.
C'est l'heure du grand comparatif.
Fausse montres contre vraies Rolex. Verdict.
Quelle est la vraie, quelle est la fausse ?
C'est assez convaincant quand même.
- Quelle est la vraie, quelle est là fausse ?
- Ça, c'est la fausse. Mais ils ont fait...
- Oui, après, quand on rentre dans le détail...
- La découpe de la lunette est différente.
Mais la vraie différence se trouve à l'intérieur des boîtiers.
Dans les entrailles de la copie, un mécanisme doré très bon marché.
- Le mouvement est à 10€.
- On sent la mauvaise qualité.
Un néophyte se fait avoir rapidement.
Moi, aujourd'hui, j'achète une montre comme ça, je la
mets en vente sur Internet avec boite et papier,
Je la mets à 2500€, la personne a eu
l'impression d'avoir fait une affaire.
Un an après, elle va aller chez le bijoutier en disant
elle s'est arrêtée ou elle a pris l'eau, elle l'amène,
On lui dit, votre montre est fausse, c'est terminé, c'est fini.
A côté des vulgaires copies, il y a un
autre marché tout aussi dangereux pour Rolex.
Celui des pièces d'occasion frelatées qui
déprécie la valeur de la montre.
Retour à New York à la grand-messe des collectionneurs.
Les passionnés se bousculent pour faire expertiser leurs joyaux.
Parmi eux, Peter Ratcliff.
Il est inquiet aujourd'hui. Il se demande
si sa montre est garantie 100% d'origine.
J'ai comme l'impression qu'il y a quelque chose qui cloche
avec le cadran de cette montre. A-t-il été retouché ?
Pouvez-vous y jeter un œil ?
En effet, le cadran a été réimprimé. Malheureusement pour cette référence de montre, c'est le cadran qui fait la valeur.
Dans l'état où est cette montre,
la valeur chute entre 8 ou 12 000$.
- Pas plus ?
- Non pas plus.
Est-ce que je peux essayer de trouver
un cadran authentique pour le remplacer ?
Oui, vous pouvez essayer. Je sais
qu'il y en a certains sur le marché,
Mais ceux qui disposent de bon cadran
Sea-Dweller a double ligne rouge,
Vont vous en demandez entre 15 et 20 000$.
- Ah oui, juste pour le cadran ?
- Oui, oui, juste pour le cadran.
Un sacré coup au moral pour Peter.
Heureusement, les vulgaires copies
ou les montres authentiques bidouillés,
Ne sont pas encore une menace absolue pour la marque à la couronne.
James Dowling en est convaincu.
Le monde de Rolex, c'est comme une petite famille. Chaque manifestation est l'occasion de grandes retrouvailles.
Pour lui, cette montre reste une valeur sûre en cas de coup dur.
La Rolex est une monnaie universelle.
Il y a un vieux proverbe qui dit,
Que si un jour tu te retrouves du mauvais côté de la ligne
de front avec des pièces d'or ou une Rolex en poche,
Tu t'en sortira toujours en les échangeant
contre un toit, de la nourriture ou une voiture.
J'ouvre l'enchère avec ce lot à 150 000$.
Dans l'univers de Rolex, un toit, c'est un château, la
nourriture, du caviar et la voiture, forcément une Rolls.
190 000, 200 000$ maintenant. Adjugé !
J'ai acheté quatorze montres pour 1 millionde dollars, la
moitié pour le business, l'autre moitié pour ma collection.
160 000, 170 000, 190 000$, adjugé !
Mon opinion est que le marché est complétement cinglé.
200 000$ pour le prototype Sea Dweller, 200 000
une fois, deux fois. Vendu pour 200 000$ !
C'est moi qui ait la montre et il en existe
très peu. Et si quelqu'un est intéressé,
Il paiera la somme que je lui demanderais.
Dans dix ans, à combien s'arrachera la dernière née
de la famille, la Deepsea, la montre des extrêmes,
Étanche à près de 4000 mètres sous l'eau.
Là où aucun plongeur n'ira jamais.
Mais peu importe. Rolex, c'est aussi du
rêve à plus de 7 000€ pour ce modèle.
Une vente aux enchères de la marque,
c'est toujours le jackpot assuré.
Nous avons vendu pour 9,2 millions
de dollars, commissions incluses.
Près de 6 millionsd'euros aujourd'hui,
certainement beaucoup plus la prochaine fois.
Car la valeur de certains modèles augmente de 5% par mois.